for the past couple of days the story
that we end up spending the rest of the
day talking about and the next day
talking about hits right around noon
eastern i was minding my own business on
monday and went to twitter to tweet out
a link of a story that i just posted
coincidentally about antonio brown not
facing league scrutiny for his recent
guilty finding of reckless driving when
he was going 100 miles an hour in the
mcknight road area of pittsburgh nfl
takes the position that doesn't fall
under the personal conduct policy
getting ready to tweet that link there
was the tweet from antonio brown thank
you steeler nation for a big nine years
time to move on and move forward
deuces emoji hashtag new demands and
so what you do if you cover the nfl for
a living and you see that you you assume
something's happened what did i miss is
there a trade deal in place that would
send the
the steelers receiver to
the 49ers to the raiders to someone
is there something going on
and i immediately started to inquire and
the responses i got were like what the
hell are you talking about well i don't
know you tell me antonio brown's saying
farewell to pittsburgh and as it turns
out there was no development
this was antonio brown just giving in to
whatever frustration may be fueling him
to try to agitate for
a trade or a release
nothing has happened in recent days
between brown and the steelers but
through the effort to figure out what
prompted this tweet it became obvious
and multiple people reported including
profootballtalk.com that brown has
officially and formally asked for a
trade from the steelers and he still
wants to be traded not a surprise if you
listened to our interview of terrell
owens from the friday before super bowl
week when it became clear that number
one owens who went through something
like this with the eagles 14 years ago
is mentoring antonio brown and owens
believed when we spoke to him a couple
of weeks ago that brown wants out and
should want out and he clearly wants out
because now he's saying goodbye before
there's an official parting of the ways
this is inching toward that shirtless
driveway
sit-ups and next question on the front
lawn press conference and drew rosenhaus
represents both guys or represent ted i
don't know what the relationship now is
between rosenhausen owens but he had
owens in 2005 and he has brown now
so i don't know they're going to take
the same approach because owens who
wanted either a new contract or an
opportunity to go to a team that would
give him one after that super bowl
performance where he would have been the
mvp if the eagles had won the super bowl
he played with the broken leg he wanted
greater protections he wanted more money
up front the eagles wouldn't give it to
him so his plan was i'm going to do
everything i can to get out of here and
it got very ugly
brown wants out is he going to do
everything he can to get out i don't
know are the steelers going to play
hardball with brown i don't know i
wouldn't recommend it
because the last thing the steelers need
is a full season long antonio brown
drama they need to move on from this
they need to turn the page on this guy
they have responsibility partial
responsibility for how it got to this
point because this guy came in
as a sixth round
pick from one of the directional
michigan universities i can't remember
which one i think it was central
michigan
and and so like he doesn't walk through
the door as a diva this isn't first
overall pick in the draft this isn't a
guy who's going to be entitled from day
one something happened that made him a
guy who
ends up being
you know chronically late a guy who ends
up
as it was reported by espn having his
own place that he stays in when the
steelers are at training camp and
everyone's crammed into dorm rooms on
those tiny dorm beds and antonio brown's
got his own place off-site there was a
tale in that espn story about antonio
brown waltzing into the locker room
while everybody was ready to go and he
wasn't even in uniform yet that's how
lady was how did it get to that point
the steelers have responsibility for
allowing it to get to that point here's
the thing they have validated antonio
brown on multiple occasions by paying
him big money in 2012. and by giving him
another contract that paid him a 19
million dollar signing bonus
only weeks
after
he broadcast
on facebook live from the locker room
after the steelers beat the chiefs in a
divisional playoff game
so his reward for that
was a new contract and now the steelers
are in this awkward spot where you got
to convince him to stay but you also
have to lay down the law good luck with
that
please stay please stay
things have better be different here
please stay please choose to stay so we
can impose all sorts of rules on you
that we've never imposed on you in the
past and make your day-to-day life more
difficult than it's ever been please
choose to stay
it's just a mess
it's not good we're going to talk to ed
bouchet of the pittsburgh post gazette
coming up he had a column last week that
argued that the steelers should
move on from antonio brown now the
question becomes
what can they get by way of trade and
when can they work it out i'm convinced
four or five weeks ago when art rooney
ii the owner of the team went public and
made it clear that the bridge was
essentially burned back to pittsburgh
that the for sale sign had been hammered
into the front yard and it was time for
the auction to start who wants antonio
brown and see that's the thing you don't
have to act like you want to keep him if
you're confident that there are multiple
teams out there that will bid the price
higher and higher and higher until the
steelers say yeah that's the guy will
trade antonio brown too and remember you
can have a deal in place at any point up
until the start of the league year it's
not official until the league year
begins at 4 pm eastern on march the 13th
but you can have the deal in place we
saw it last year when alex smith was
traded to washington the deal was in
place weeks before the deal could become
official but there's been no deal which
tells us the steelers haven't gotten the
offers they thought they were going to
get so what do they do now especially
with brown saying goodbye to pittsburgh
that's not going to help this dealers
get more
that's going to make it harder for them
to get what they want and i think what
they need to do now you hold on to
antonio brown until after the first
couple of days of free agency and maybe
once the dust settles maybe once any of
the big names that make it to the market
get signed by other teams teams that
need receivers may suddenly want antonio
brown
so
i
here's the problem too two and a half
million dollars is doing payable to
antonio brown the fifth day of the
league year what do you do do you trade
him before it or do you just pay the
money and hope that the trade offers get
better after the fact because i think
the best window to trade him at this
point may be after round one of the
draft remember there's like 18 hours
between round one and round two it's
been that way for about 10 years now so
after a team that may have been
targeting a receiver in round one and
doesn't get that receiver
after that team kind of goes back
to plan where we go from here we still
have this glaring need at receiver
maybe second round pick third round pick
whatever the case may be gets offered to
the steelers then for antonio brown
so that's the challenge the steelers
face i think that it's important to get
this thing cleared up soon
but from the steelers perspective
maximizing the return on brown may
require allowing this to play out even
if it means paying him two and a half
million dollars on the fifth day of the
league year in march then there's the
fact that whoever acquires antonio brown
you know he's due to make just under 39
million over the next three years that's
just under 13 million a year that's
pretty good as the receiver market goes
with there's no guaranteed money nothing
you've got you've got maximum control of
his rights you've got flexibility you're
not locked into a 40 million dollar
payment so yeah hey we'll give you a
second or third round pick for this guy
when it's an advantageous contract for
us here's the problem
brown's probably gonna want another bite
from the apple he's already had two
long-term deals
he's probably gonna want another one as
part of his arrival in a new city
what do you do
do you trade for a guy who walks through
the door and says i want more money and
you say no
and then he's as disgruntled with you as
he is in pittsburgh
that's one of the complications here
that doesn't get discussed much
but
i think it's a safe bet
that brown is going to be looking to
enhance his financial package with
whoever would trade for him and he's
going to want guaranteed money he's
going to want a signing bonus he's going
to want injury guarantees he's going to
want a higher per year average because
there are guys out there now who are
making more than he makes and he's going
to want to say i'm still the best
receiver and the best evidence that i'm
the best receiver is that i'm making
more money than any other receiver so
there's a lot of moving parts here
and through it all the steelers are
looking at 21 million cap charge if they
cut or trade this guy i
i i know that that teams especially the
steelers they were very used to
dictating terms to their players and the
players don't dictate terms to them well
they've been through this with le'veon
bell the past couple of years where bell
has dictated terms to them and they
don't like it so now does that make them
more determined to push back with
antonio brown because see if you make it
too easy for a guy to get out of town
you have to worry about the next guy and
the next guy and the next guy but at a
time when the steelers have so many of
these issues so much drama so many
distractions do you really want this do
you want antonio brown there when he is
determined to get out do you want your
2019 season to be marred by
antonio brown
wanting out of pittsburgh what are the
other veteran players going to say
what's ben roethlisberger going to say
what are these other players going to
believe what are they going to feel how
are they going to regard another lost
opportunity to compete for a
championship as the patriots are in the
process of potentially leapfrogging the
steelers with seven super bowl trophies
now that both teams are tied with six
these are just some of the issues that
the steelers are gonna have to deal with
and ed buschetta the pittsburgh post
gazette has been all over the antonio
browns story we're gonna talk to ed
bushette about how it got to this point
where it goes from here and how he
believes based upon
decades of covering the steelers they
are going to find a way out of this maze
in a manner that does minimal damage to
the franchise and the team's hopes for
2019
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports